my name is Delaney Baker I am a musician
in Nashville this is my wife Tommy and
this is our story towards debt freedom
we got married fairly young I was right
out of college and to say we were broke
would be an exaggeration we had no money
what happened three years and three
months ago that inspired this big change
in your life to get out of that we both
had separate checking accounts I didn't
know what he was bringing in I didn't
know how much money we made I had no
clue she was working in a salon about
the time that I was playing in a cover
band
that was doing really well I always had
cash in my pocket we went into that
summer and it was like okay that's fine
you know and I didn't watch where it
went and so it just slipped through my
fingers like water the winter months are
slow for a musician gigs kind of slow
down Christmas break take some of my
students so it was December of 2011 when
I realized that I didn't have money to
pay rent in January and I don't think
the stress that he was feeling even
registered to me because every time
money was tight he would always find
work it didn't click to me that we were
in trouble she didn't know because we
weren't talking about it I was so
emotionally wrecked that I brought it
all the God got down on my knees ugly
cry pull your heart out prayer and it
was we need to do this better we can do
this better and I don't know what that
looks like yet but I'm open to learning
I hadn't felt the weight and felt the
pain of the debt until that December
you're like okay god I need some help
here that's right and he looks over at
Gabriel goes hey look
and woke up so I reached out to a friend
of mine David Stevenson and asked him
for his help
sitting down and doing my taxes Davis
said hey look we're actually starting an
FPU class and we would like for you guys
to attend we got a plan of action
together it's it's so much fun I started
really meal planning and couponing and
making laundry so it was exciting to
know that we could work together a
common goal so we were a year and a half
into the plan
$56,000 when we started so we had paid
off twenty five thousand dollars at this
point we were living in a three-bedroom
house with a huge backyard paying rent
to my parents who owned the place and we
get a call saying your dad's job may be
in jeopardy we have to sell the house I
wonder by
my heart wanted to buy it just because
we'd made it home it was a heartbreaking
yeah
but on the other hand and we're still
30-some thousand dollars in debt if we
moved into much smaller apartment and it
was like a smack in the face it was
reality setting in this is what it means
to be living within our means we realize
we are very spoiled you've paid off
fifty six thousand dollars yeah one of
the secrets to getting out of debt
communication sitting down and doing the
budget we did it weekly yes we did when
we attended FPU we realized the
importance of sitting down and doing a
budget weekly and making sure that we
launched every penny Thursdays or our
days off and we get up and make coffee
and make a big breakfast we'll play
cards and then we'll sit down and get to
business it became one of the sweetest
times of the week just because we were
living with an irregular income we can
no longer use that as an excuse what we
gave up in order to maintain our heading
we look back at now and I'm grateful it
was a temporary pain I never got a
chance to take my wife on a honeymoon
and so we just save up hasn't always
been easy and there been many dissonant
moments where we felt discouraged and
defeated
but looking back those times were
essential to creating a deeper
appreciation just how sweet and
meaningful this verse of our lives has
been you can't wait to start the next